la chronique de l'innovation bonsoir
sophie ça nous allons parler de nos
voitures mais des voitures du futur
absolument pas ce que vous connaissez
certainement les petites voitures
téléguidées
mais les voitures taille réelle que l'on
peut commander depuis un smartphone
c'est assez récent alors google et
nissan s'était déjà mis mais maintenant
c'est une entreprise de
montigny-le-bretonneux saint-quentinoise
qui s'y met avec une start up parisienne
c'est pour ça que nous recevons sur ce
plateau à la fois jean marc leroux qui
est donc pdg de la société aeris la
start up parisienne
et puis également pierre duguay vous
êtes responsable innovation chez adm
concept merci d'être venus tout d'abord
vous avez d'abord amené ici un élément
qui peut servir dans le système de
télécommande à distance c'est ça tout à
fait ce qu'on montre ici en fait c'est
l'exemple l'interface qu'on a mis au
point pour piloter la voiture à distance
c'est comme un jeu vidéo c'est comme un
jeu vidéo alors c'est un peu de garde de
dire ça alors ni comment ça fonctionne
comment ça fonctionne me dit
qu'effectivement alors là c'était celui
dit qu'un c'est vraiment le but c'est de
montrer une démonstration c'est pas du
tout le genre de produit qu'on pourrait
avoir dans la vraie vie
le but du projet c'est de montrer avant
tout qu'on peut connecter la voiture et
qu'on peut la connecter à tout
l'environnement numérique qui existe
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir par
exemple on peut commander koala depuis
votre commande est selon toute la
voiture ce qu'on a mis en avant ici
c'est notamment le contrôle de la
direction et de la propulsion donc on
peut littéralement faire avancer la
voiture et la faire tourner allumez les
clignotants allumés les phares donc les
contrôles de base mais ce qui est
important c'est que toute la voiture est
connecté on peut envoyer des commandes
mais on peut aussi avoir des
informations sur la voiture en temps
réel il reste c'est très joli c'est un
joli jouet mais c'est pas dangereux
alors le but encore une fois ce n'est
pas du tout les gens conduisent avec
leur smartphone là c'est de montrer que
c'est possible technologiquement le
point fort de la technologie qu'on a
déployé c'est vraiment
l'interopérabilité donc le but c'est pas
que les gens pilote la voiture avec leur
smartphone mais que par exemple un
parking le parking de l'hôtel ou de
l'aéroport puisse se connecter à la
voiture et la piloter hui
manière sûre dans un environnement fermé
on va développer tout ça comment ça
fonctionne un petit peu d'air pour
rentrer dans la technique sans envie
rentrer trop pour qu'on comprenne
toujours mais comment ça marche c'est un
système wifi entre la voiture et le
smartphone oui aujourd'hui en fait la
voiture donc qui est fournie par adm
concept montre partenaires elle est
équipée d'un réseau wifi est donc assez
simplement tous les périphériques
avoisinant peuvent se connecter au wifi
des voitures et échanger avec elle ça
marche partout
admettons que je suis en rase campagne
je ne capte pas internet mais je peux
communiquer avec ma voiture alors dans
le cannabis lequel louis dans
l'application que nous avons là s'il
s'agit d'un wifi tout à fait ponctuel
puisque les voitures étaient préparés à
l'origine pour répondre à l'appel à
projet du conseiller gère les yvelines
sur le thème valets de parking et donc
c'est une application très très local
qui permet à la voiture d'aller se garer
toute seule
c'est pour ça qu'elle est déjà très
équipés
au niveau des automatismes de contrôle
et de et de ses actionnaires et qu'ils
aient qui l'attend permis de la commande
et l'extérieur très facilement c'est ce
que j'allais vous demandez alors
concrètement ça sert à quoi qu'elles
sont qu'est ce qu'on peut imaginer comme
utilité à cette commande de loin parce
que bon c'est bien gentil de mettre un
clignotant à distance mais on a du mal à
quoi ça sert il est bien évident qu'on
va pas s'amuser à conduire les voitures
comme ça de l'extérieur demain matin
c'est pas le sujet mais il ya des
applications qui sont tout à fait à
portée de la portée de main et ont
commencé qu'est-ce qu'on paye notamment
dans le domaine des voitures électriques
une application intéressante et de
commandes est tout simplement la mise en
route de la climatisation pendant que la
voiture est encore en charge ou
également de piloter la mise en charge
de la voiture pour que ça se fasse à des
heures de moindres de moindres coûts de
l'edf électrique donc dans le cas des
voitures électriques
bon ça c'est des choses qui vont arriver
tout de suite quoi donc du confort sont
allés sinon actionné
d'autres actions à partir d'un
smartphone pour au niveau des voitures
pour ces choses que l'on pratique déjà
puisque dans le cadre de l'auto partage
puisque c'est un domaine dans lequel
sont très impliqués maintenant y compris
pour les twizy de 50 ha
ces voitures là donc sont actionnées
avec un lecteur de cartes
donc on amène sa carte mais tout de
suite après avoir utilisé immédiatement
derrière donc dès qu'on sera un peu plus
installés en france on pour faire la
même chose avec un téléphone via le
réseau lfc et nous avions fait pour se
rendre de paris une voiture pour orange
d'ailleurs démonstrateur de cette
manière et voilà et dans les études on
va même plus loin
voilà le passé devant la vitre sur le
piège alors un petit peu tous les toutes
les configurations de commander une
voiture de l'extérieur et y compris par
sms non nous avons un démonstrateur chez
nous qui est une kangoo électrique de
renault est commandée par un chômage
plus que jamais il ne faut pas se faire
voler son téléphone portable
voilà en tout cas voilà faire attention
alors les voitures intelligentes ça a de
quoi étonner parfois même peut-être
inquiété on a posé la question aux saint
quentinois pour savoir ce qu'ils
pensaient de ces voitures à
l'intelligence artificielle un petit peu
quand même ça peut être très dangereux
non pas particulièrement pas plus que
les voitures électriques dont tout le
monde au départ a dit ça va être
horrible parce qu'on va pas les entendre
ça va causer des accidents et au final
ça a l'air de plutôt bien se passer
bien sûr que ça fait peur parce que
c'est pas nous qui contrôlons vais je
dire qu'à tout moment ça bug rendant un
mur seules qui choisissent non contre la
faim pour la colle blanche pas ce cap
est une solution
ma foi j'ai pas le permis donc ça serait
cool oui quand même indiqué je trouve
que la mécanique c'est pas toujours très
bien c'est parfait parce que c'est une
mauvaise contre ça peut être intéressant
mais en même temps
une véritable confiance sur la mécanique
pas forcément au niveau la sécurité
routière main ça permettrait de montrer
qu'il ya un contrôle et que tout le
monde respecte ses alliés ses limites
alors évidemment ça pose des questions
est-ce qu'il va falloir je vous pose la
question à tous les deux développer un
permis spécial commandé de six ans par
exemple permis smartphones a permis
smartphones vu qu a priori le but c'est
pas vraiment de bordères un puissant
smartphone a priori non mais ce qui va
falloir faire effectivement c'est
adapter la législation et développer de
nouveaux services
parmi les services qu on précisait par
exemple c'est pas seulement de commander
la voiture maire de l'information par
exemple votre assureur pour avoir des
informations sur tous les capteurs de la
voiture au lieu d'aller en révision tous
les ans vous pourrez avoir ensuite en
réel et sa pente il faut adapter la
législation et les contrats d'assurance
par exemple ouais alors ça c'est toutes
les évolutions de la voiture
intelligentes et communicantes sais plus
est-ce que c'est pas finalement qu'un
simple gadget il ya des applications
pour la sécurité et ça a déjà commencé
comment sait on peut moi j'ai suivi des
flottes la géolocalisation des horreurs
des remontées d'informations pour nous
et puis même pour l'entreprise sont déjà
très équipé le conducteur même sa purée
avoir des applications avec des
communications sur la distance minimale
si elle est respectée ou pas sur wii
dans sas pratique lalanne aux vauzelles
s'élance de c'est de prendre un
raccourci du téléphone directement aux
véhicules quoi sinon c'est ce genre de
des échanges d'informations se pratique
déjà ce qu'on peut être aujourd'hui
parce que c'est que la voiture peut se
connecter directement au péage et payer
le péage avant qu'on y arrive parce que
la voiture à les connecter vraiment à
tous les objets qui sont autour
aujourd'hui la technologie qu'on a
installé sur la voiture ddm pm concept
c'est plus de 10 milliards d'objets dans
le monde qui sont compatibles ils
peuvent se connecter et interagit avec
la nature donc les possibilités elles
sont vraiment un fini c'est à dire 10
milliards d'objets tous les objets
électroniques sont compatibles et c'est
vraiment la force de la technologie
qu'installer c'est l'état bête c'est
vraiment un exemple parmi tant d'autres
mais les serveurs de votre banque de
votre assureur le télépéage tout peut se
connecter et interagit avec la voiture
et le but les surfaces en toute sécurité
évidemment c'est le partage des données
on
devenu complètement c'est big brother
quoi c'est la voiture est un des objets
de l'internet des objets celles ci
permettent d'éviter des accidents aussi
ou des personnes qui conduirait on
entendu dans le micro tout à revoir tout
à l'heure une personne qui disait ben
justement en état d'ébriété ça peut
aussi être qu'elle servir à quelque
chose ou soient contrées pas là dessus
poursuit par croire que n'est capable de
remplacer la responsabilité du
conducteur mais ça peut permettre de
détecter d'autres véhicules autour de
soi aussi pour que la voiture prennent
la main et freine automatiquement les
dictées non parce que ce serait plutôt
des capteurs mais pente de s'y connecter
pour interagir avec intelligemment oui
par exemple peut-être adapter limitateur
de vitesse pour éviter les bouchons
puisqu'on sait que les bouchons c'est
causé par le fait qu'on freine ou qu'on
accélère de manière appropriée donc ça
pourrait paraître de régulier peut être
un peu mieux le trafic par ici après sa
pause toute la question du des dangers
aussi de l'électronique grandissant dans
les voitures qui existent déjà par
exemple avec les limitateur de vitesse
il ya des
risque qui n'existait pas avant c'est ce
bloc même qui se bloquent
c'est assez effrayant aussi ça va oui
enfin bon il faut il ya il faut prendre
et les cédantes certains toutes les
informations qu'il a pu y avoir là
dessus
ce sont des quatre est extrêmement rare
et en tout cas beaucoup moins développé
que toute la publicité qui en a été fait
ça inquiète forcément les idées ça
montre qu'il faut vraiment avant une
dans une collaboration entre les gens
qui font les voitures et les gens qui
font logiciels et qu'il faut à mon avis
rien que d'imaginer que créer des
logiciels et crée deux des voitures
objets mécaniques c'est le mbc
il faut collaborer se faire confiance
contre bas par exemple contraire au
respect des start up
écoutez la voiture sont déjà très très
sophistiqué sur le plan de
l'intelligence un haut niveau de
systèmes de freinage d'antipatinage à
des calculateurs très très très puissant
donc tout ce site avait à peu près
maîtrisée voilà donc c'est le moment de
travail et mais les constructeurs les
équipementiers prennent leurs
dispositions pour pour avoir une
fiabilité qui garantit le le grand
public
quand est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
conduire ces voitures d'ailleurs
intelligente même question enfin les
contrôles et qu'on a par une voiture
intelligente d'ornement l'instant c'est
d'avoir deux modes d'utilisation en mode
automatique est en mode
en mode manuel pour le donc dans la
presse en exercice que nous avons fait
et de la manière dont il est équipé donc
cette voiture là donc
elle permet par exemple d'arriver au
parking mettons de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines pour les pans de son
train pour poster voiture on va prendre
son train la barrière sourd et la
voiture s'en va tout seul trouver une
place dans le parking c'est le parking
qui la planète voilà donc c'est le petit
film que vous montrez un petit extrait
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs sur l'écran
cette voiture intelligente qui
communique avec son parking
donc il ya donc un ennemi qu'est ce que
ça va arriver en vrai ça on se dit oh
toi c'est le futur édition intégrale
il est très très lent dans très
longtemps parce que même google qui fait
de la publicité sur ses voitures et tout
une
n'oublie pas de rappeler que
on verra pas ça avant 10 ou 15 ans et
que et que l'équipement nécessaire pour
faire ça représente en gros
cent quarante mille dollars donc ce
n'est peut-être pas tout de suite c'est
quoi pour le vrai automatismes donc sur
l'arbre tour une voiture des
applications beaucoup plus simples comme
aller dans un parking ça ça c'est chose
qu'on pourra faire de façon beaucoup
plus raisonnables et a beaucoup plus
court terme
maintenant ça veut dire qu'il faut
placer quand elles sont protégés et non
où il n'ya pas d'interférence entre les
usagers et puis le véhicule automatique
l'émotion les voitures récentes qui sont
a priori activement bien équipé pour
pour d'ores et déjà faire ce genre d
applications par exemple la voiture et
des voitures renault qui sont équipés
d'une connexion 3g et donc qu'ils
peuvent se connecter à leur
environnement la question s'est il faut
vraiment travailler entre industriels et
éditeur logiciel et c'est vraiment ça
qui va pouvoir faire qu'on pourra
arriver à quelque chose à lui plaint une
odyssée de morneau airlink cela permet
justement de va permettre très vite
d'actionner par le téléphone ce que je
disais tout à l'heure donc la
programmation du chauffage que attend de
prendre en compte le véhicule électrique
et puis et la programmation également de
la recharge
bon ça va pas ça ne va pas au delà on ne
va pas on va pas interférer sur la
conduite
il va y avoir des bêta test j'ai vu de
ces voitures prochainement c'est ça
l'est peut-être je vais le tester sur
les patinoires de validation grenoble
non mais sur votre votre système de
commande à distance sur à des tests
prochainement nous on fait partie depuis
depuis un mois de même que batteur
renault qui est dans le sud est de paris
donc le but effectivement c'est
d'attirer leur attention sur ces sujets
là et de pouvoir au cours du partenariat
mettre en place un prototype tel que
celui là c'est trop tôt pour dire
exactement ce qu'on pourra produire avec
renault mais l'idée c'est vraiment de
montrer que technologiquement c'est
possible et que maintenant et c'est plus
qu'une question de vouloir le faire tant
il moyen exactement autant les moyens
merci à tous les deux ans à venir pour
cette chronique de l'innovation on
termine par une offre en plus une petite
info en plus je vous présente encore un
chercheur cette semaine ou plutôt une
chercheuse parité oblige il
il s'agit de nathalie carrasco qui est
chimiste a lu vs q
elle vient d'être nominée à l'institut
universitaire de france pour la qualité
de sa recherche à travers sur quoi est
elle travaille notamment sur
l'atmosphère de titan qui est le plus
gros satellite de saturne et ça permet
de comprendre notamment comment est ce
que la terre s'est formé merci pour
cette chronique de l'innovation vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine en plateau